This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。百分之二。这是当电梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目“2%”中，我将剖析我们在奇怪的现代世界中培养精神坚韧、体能和抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听“2%”。也就是TWO。下载iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts，或在各大播客平台收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
他将罪有应得。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台收听。在“Look Back at it”播客中。对1979年来说，那对我是一个重要时刻。84年对我很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们都会选择一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台收听“Look Back at it”。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在其他任何地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。多少男人穿着一套盔甲。这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要去使用它。在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台收听并学习《Learn the Hard Way》。
Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. We are going to talk about something a little bit different today, a concept that you may or may not have heard of, which is toxic positivity. Even if you haven't heard of it, you've most likely experienced it in some form. People, you know, telling you. you to keep your chin up, that everything happens for a reason to think good thoughts and they'll become your reality because toxic positivity is everywhere these days, especially with the rise of a lot of Instagram and TikTok self-help content. It is essentially this belief or this attitude that a positive mindset fixes everything. Whatever it is you're going through,
大家好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨20多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转型，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到这个播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里收听新的一期节目，当然，我们要剖析20多岁的心理学。今天我们要聊点稍微不同的东西，一个你可能听说过也可能没听说过的概念，那就是毒性积极（盲目乐观）。即使你没听说过，你也极有可能是以某种形式经历过它。人们，你知道的，会告诉你，要昂首挺胸，发生的一切都有原因，去想美好的事情，它们就会成为你的现实，因为毒性积极现在无处不在，特别是随着大量Instagram和TikTok自助内容的兴起。它本质上是一种信念或态度，即积极的心态能解决一切问题。无论你正在经历什么，
being optimistic will make it better. And it's an attitude that has a lot of consequences for our mental health, for our emotional well-being, but also for our emotional intelligence and our ability to actually address our emotions and solve our problems. I have to admit, I have been guilty of perhaps promoting this kind of messaging, both to myself and you guys, the listeners. It is very easy to villainize negative emotions or so-called negative emotions because they simply just don't feel nice. You know, feeling angry doesn't feel nice. Feeling distressed, disappointed doesn't feel nice.
保持乐观会让情况变好。这种态度对我们的心理健康、情感福祉，以及对我们的情商和实际处理情绪、解决问题的能力，都会产生很多负面影响。我必须承认，我可能也曾内疚于推广过这种信息，无论是对我自己还是对你们这些听众。妖魔化消极情绪或所谓的消极情绪是非常容易的，因为它们感觉实在不够美妙。你知道，感到愤怒感觉并不好。感到痛苦、失望感觉也并不好。
And putting a positive spin on things kind of erases the need to truly feel and process these big feelings. But maturing is recognizing that just because something doesn't feel nice doesn't mean it's not useful. And second to that, emotions like grief, like despair, like disappointment, and rejection, they are what makes us human. And being able to connect with those emotions means that we are able to connect with ourselves, firstly with our experiences, but also with others.
给事情加上积极的滤镜，在某种程度上就抹杀了去真正感受和处理这些强烈情感的需求。但走向成熟意味着认识到，一件事情感觉不好并不意味着它没有用。除此之外，像悲伤、绝望、失望和被拒绝这样的情绪，正是它们让我们成为人。能够与这些情绪建立连接，意味着我们能够首先与自己建立连接，与我们的经历建立连接，同时也能够与他人建立连接。
It's a real privilege to sometimes not feel amazing all the time. Personally, I also think that toxic positivity is really dangerous during our 20s in particular because, you know, our emotions can teach us so much during this period, and they do influence who we are becoming. So if we mask them by being overly positive about everything, by not letting anything in, by numbing ourselves out, we're kind of doing ourselves a disservice. And it may sound strange to hear me say that, you know,
有时不能一直感觉好极了，这其实是一种特权。就我个人而言，我也认为毒性积极在我们的20多岁时特别危险，因为你知道，在这段时期里，我们的情绪可以教给我们很多东西，它们确实影响着我们正在成为什么样的人。因此，如果我们通过对一切都过度积极、不让任何东西进来、麻木自己来掩盖它们，我们其实是在做对自己不利的事。听到我这么说可能会觉得奇怪，你知道，
being too positive is a danger to you is dangerous, because how can something so nice be so dangerous? But when we gravitate towards the same reaction for all of our experiences, i.e. always looking for the bright side, no matter how hard or difficult something is, we do tend to suppress a lot of what makes us so tender and so unique and so vulnerable in that vulnerability is a good thing. So today we are going to discuss the problem with always being positive, and I know it sounds strange, but why feeling bad is sometimes good for you. We'll also dive into why it is that we tend to gravitate towards optimism. This constant,
过度积极对你来说是危险的，因为怎么会有这么美好的事情这么危险呢？但是，当我们对所有的经历都倾向于做出相同的反应，即无论事情多么艰难或困难，总是寻找光明面时，往往会压抑很多让我们变得如此温柔、独特和脆弱的东西，而这种脆弱是一件好事。所以今天我们要讨论总是保持积极的问题所在，我知道这听起来很奇怪，但为什么感觉糟糕有时对你有好处。我们还将探讨为什么我们倾向于对乐观趋之若鹜。这种不断的、
of self-inflicted emotional gaslighting and the alternative. What is the alternative to putting a positive spin on things? Where does this inclination come from? We're going to talk about the origins of shame and emotional embarrassment. And I think that once you realize how common this radical optimism, this unrealistic optimism is, you'll be surprised how often you notice it and you'll be surprised how rampant it is in our society. Once you begin to notice it, you'll never stop noticing it. But we also, of course, want to give you an alternative. We want to talk about what it is that we can do, because if we can't make our emotions feel good,
自我施加的情感煤气灯效应以及替代方案。给事情加上积极滤镜的替代方案是什么？这种倾向从何而来？我们将讨论羞耻感和情感尴尬的根源。我想，一旦你意识到这种激进的乐观主义、这种不切实际的乐观主义是多么普遍，你就会惊讶于自己注意到它的频率，也会惊讶于它在我们的社会中是多么猖獗。一旦你开始注意到它，你将永远不会停止注意到它。但当然，我们也想给你一个替代方案。我们想讨论我们可以做什么，因为如果我们不能让我们的情绪感觉良好，
what's the alternative? Do we just let them exist? Well, yeah, that's the answer. There we go. Episode summed up. No, we'll be talking about that a little bit more. And I think that's all. That's all that I have. Without further ado, let's get into it.
替代方案是什么？我们就让它们存在吗？嗯，是的，这就是答案。就这样。本期节目总结完毕。不，我们会对此进行更多讨论。我想这就是全部了。这就是我所要说的全部内容。废话不多说，我们开始吧。
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex soon. pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
2%。这就是当电梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客“2%”中，我将剖析在奇怪的现代世界中培养精神坚韧、体能和抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以超越健康产业中那些不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。
Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett.
收听“2%”。也就是T-W-O-Percent。在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA上拍了两次小金姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金姆有什么关系？好吧，你可以在“Look Back at it”播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of Iraq. crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point,
我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们都会选择一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，畅谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。可卡因。我随时都可以聊快克，不过为了让大家知道我的意思。我的意思是，在这一点上，
this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most
这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始发现它们之间有一条贯穿线。我们现在还讨论了艾滋病。谢谢你把话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最
important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience
重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台收听“Look Back at it”。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了致敬心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，
in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时我们在追求某事时，会过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines,
史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世时做一个好人很重要？你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。这是两种不同信任层面的事情。我希望你真的能成为一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，
as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，我们进行关于疗愈、成长、父职、压力和目标的真实对话。打开免费的iHeart Radio App。搜索“Learn the Hard Way”并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法院听证会暴露了她故事中显而易见的矛盾之处。这引发了一场历时多年的法庭之战来证明真相。
You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini.
你伪造了这个特定测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案件。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice of. served in Arizona.
我的大脑炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Toxic positivity has a few different names. The first time that it was labeled was back in the 1980s. And back then it was known as unrealistic optimism. It's also known as bright-siding, positive tyranny, which is very dramatic. But I think you get the picture. At the end of the day, all these terms are referring to the same thing.
这一切都不会结束。在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台收听“Love Trapped”播客。毒性积极（盲目乐观）有几个不同的名字。它第一次被贴上标签是在20世纪80年代。在那时，它被称为不切实际的乐观主义。它也被称为“只看光明面”（bright-siding）或“积极暴政”（positive tyranny），这听起来非常戏剧化。但我想你明白我的意思。归根结底，所有这些术语指的都是同一件事：
a deep but also toxic and maladaptive belief that thinking positively can erase all negative feelings and that those negative feelings are bad. We have bad emotions that we should not feel and the way to not feel them is to cover them in sugar and cover them in sunshine and always find the positive, always try and shake it off. We want to prioritize upbeat thinking, we want to push down the difficult stuff. No one wants to see that. No one wants to feel that. can't be positive all the time, you have somehow failed, something is wrong with you. This can be a belief that we've learned from someone else around us, or it can be self-imposed, like feeling guilty when you feel sad or disappointed and immediately forcing yourself
一种根深蒂固但又充满毒性且适应不良的信念，即积极的思考可以抹杀所有的负面情绪，并且那些负面情绪是坏事。我们拥有不应该感受的坏情绪，而不去感受它们的方法就是给它们裹上糖衣，涂上阳光，总是寻找积极的一面，总是试图摆脱它们。我们想要优先考虑乐观的心态，我们要压抑困难的东西。没有人想看到那些。没有人想去感受那些。如果你不能一直保持积极，你就在某种程度上失败了，你出了问题。这可能是我们从周围其他人那里学到的信念，也可能是强加给自己的，比如当你感到悲伤或失望时感到内疚，并立即强迫自己
to think about everything you should be grateful for instead of letting yourself be sad, or pushing down big feelings by telling yourself, it could be worse. Just move on. This is why toxic positivity is sometimes seen as a form of self-inflicted emotional gaslighting. That is a mouthful, but I think we're all pretty familiar with the term gaslighting when it comes to romantic relationships. It's this act of one person manipulating somebody else into questioning their own reality and what is actually true or real as a way to maintain control over them. When we force ourselves to push down and push aside
去想所有你本该感激的事情，而不是让自己去悲伤，或者通过告诉自己“情况可能会更糟”来压抑强烈的情感。继续前进吧。这就是为什么毒性积极有时被视为一种自我施加的情感煤气灯效应（情感虐待/操纵）。这是一个拗口的词，但当涉及到恋爱关系时，我想我们对“煤气灯效应”这个词都相当熟悉。这是一个人的行为，他操纵另一个人去质疑他们自己的现实以及什么是真实或真实的，以此来对他们保持控制。当我们强迫自己压抑和推开
hard emotions, the premise is that we are essentially gaslighting ourselves by saying, this isn't real. You don't know what you're experiencing, you're choosing to feel bad about this. Rather than you feel bad about this because it's hard. And that's a normal reaction. This experience is real and raw and it's okay to be in pain and to be flat for a while. This is hard. You can feel sad about it. More often than not, though, toxic positivity is something that we experience from others. there is of course that own sense of like almost self-preservation, I would call it, to maintain a positive outlook at all times. But there are often these times when perhaps you go to a therapist or a family member or a friend
艰难的情绪时，其前提是我们本质上是在对自己进行煤气灯效应，对自己说：“这不是真的。你不知道你在经历什么，你是选择对这件事感觉糟糕。”而不是“你对这件事感觉糟糕是因为它很艰难。”这是一种正常的反应。这种经历是真实而生硬的，处于痛苦之中或一段时间内情绪低落是没有问题的。这很难。你可以为此感到难过。然而，更多的时候，毒性积极是我们从别人那里经历到的。当然，有一种几乎可以称为自我保护的自身感觉，即在任何时候都保持积极的视角。但通常会有这样的时候，也许你去找治疗师、家人或朋友，
and you say, you know, I'm just really struggling with this thing. This terrible thing is happening. I'm really stressed. I'm really tired. I'm really exhausted. And the only thing they try and do is get you to see the positive sides. They only try and get you to see the light at the end of the tunnel. And I get it.
然后你说：“你知道的，我真的在为这件事苦恼。这件糟糕的事情发生了。我压力真的很大。我真的很累。我真的筋疲力尽了。”而他们唯一试图做的就是让你看到积极的一面。他们只想让你看到隧道尽头的曙光。我懂。
I really do get why a family member or a friend or a therapist or anybody would want to bring us back to what is good. Because we don't like to see other people struggle. We don't like to see other people feel sad, especially people that we love. You know, some examples of this are like when you go through a breakup and you're immediately told that, you know, there's someone better out there. Think about the positives in the situation. Think about how fun it's going to be single. when you perhaps aren't ready to hear that. Losing your job and being told that, you know, you can have it worse.
我真的理解为什么家人、朋友、治疗师或任何人会想要把我们带回到美好的事物中。因为我们不喜欢看到别人挣扎。我们不喜欢看到别人感到悲伤，尤其是我们爱的人。你知道，这的一些例子就像当你经历分手时，别人立刻告诉你，你知道的，外面有更好的人。想想这种情况下的积极因素。想想单身会有多有趣。或者当你可能还没准备好听到这些时。失去工作并被告知，你知道的，情况可能会更糟。
Some people don't even have a job. Some people don't even have savings. Some people have been unemployed so much longer than you. So chin up. It's all that line of thinking, you know, getting ghosted, getting rejected and being told that everything happens for a reason. Yes, it's a nice thought. It just might not be helpful.
有些人甚至没有工作。有些人甚至没有存款。有些人的失业时间比你长得多。所以昂首挺胸吧。所有这些思路，你知道的，被冷落，被拒绝，并被告知发生的一切都有原因。是的，这是一个美好的想法。只是它可能没有帮助。
And it's probably one of those thoughts that's only helpful in hindsight when you're ready to hear it. what's another example that we see a lot oh somebody was telling me about this the other day living like when you um go and like see a friend or you're with a family member or whoever it is and you just feel like you can't be low energy because they'll immediately pathologize or think that something is wrong so
而且这可能只是那种只有在事后当你准备好倾听时才会有帮助的想法。还有什么我们经常看到的例子？哦，前几天有人跟我聊起这个，生活就像是，当你去见一个朋友，或者和家人在一起，无论他是谁，你只是觉得你不能处于低能量状态，因为他们会立即将其病理化或认为出了什么问题，所以
if you're like oh i've just had a really bad day they'll immediately be like well that's not good no no no no we don't want you to have a bad day let's like make this better we need to think positive We need to fix your problem when you might just be having a bad day. Or over-emphasizing the power of gratitude. That is something that we see all the time. I had an example from a friend. Well, yeah, from a friend and acquaintance who was telling me about how one of her co-workers
如果你说“哦，我今天过得真的很糟糕”，他们会立刻说“哦，那可不好，不不不不，我们可不希望你过得糟糕，让我们把它变好，我们需要积极思考。我们需要解决你的问题”，而你可能只是单纯地度过了糟糕的一天。或者过度强调感恩的力量。这是我们经常看到的事情。我有一个朋友的例子。好吧，是的，一个朋友和熟人告诉我，她的一个同事
lost her mother to cancer really unexpectedly. And of course, dealing with that just humongous grief, unimaginable grief. She went and saw a therapist, and the therapist, or it was a counsellor, told her to make a gratitude list to help her feel better. And you know what? I get that her intentions were most likely in the right place. But you can also see how this is probably not helpful. That's probably not the one thing that we need to do. This is almost a denial of the negative emotions and an unrealistic promotion of positive thinking when this person probably would actually not benefit from immediately moving on.
非常意外地因癌症失去了母亲。当然，要应对那种巨大的悲伤，难以想象的悲伤。她去看了一位治疗师，而那个治疗师，或者说顾问，告诉她去做一张感恩清单来帮助她感觉好点。你知道吗？我明白她的意图很可能是出于好意。但你也能看出这可能并没有什么帮助。这可能不是我们需要做的唯一一件事。这几乎是对负面情绪的否定，是对积极思考的不切实际的推崇，而这个人可能实际上并没有从立即向前看中受益。
That's what I get the point of like, oh yeah, what are you grateful for so you don't dwell on this loss, but maybe it would have been better to just be like, yeah, that's really, really awful, that really sucks. Let's just let you feel really bad about that for a while because that is a completely reasonable thing to be feeling. One final example, because I'm filled with anecdotes today, is this experience, this concept out of order to this, a term known as bright sighting. And we see this a lot when someone tells us a story about something really frustrating or really terrible or painful and immediately somebody else jumps in with a matching story of their own that is
这就是我的观点所在，噢，是的，你感激什么，这样你就不会纠结于这种失落，但也许更好的做法是直接说：“是的，这真的很糟糕，这太烂了。让我们先让你为此难过一会儿吧，因为这是一种完全合理的感受。”最后一个例子，因为我今天充满了各种轶事，就是这种经历，这个脱离顺序的概念，一个被称为“只看光明面”（bright sighting）的术语。当我们听到有人讲述关于某件非常令人沮丧、非常糟糕或痛苦的事情的故事时，这种情况经常发生，然后另一个人立刻插话，讲一个他们自己的、
far more terrible and far more painful. Or they point out, the one part of the story where something good happened or something worse could have happened, you know, oh, I just had the most terrible commute to work today. I was so frustrated. I was so angry by the time I got in. I just like didn't want to be there. And then they go, well, on the bright side, like at least, you know, what happened to me today? Well, at least, you know, your car didn't explode like mine, so you have something to feel good about. It's like, well, when that happens, it immediately immediately kind of cuts off your ability to express your feelings because you either feel the need to justify the experience or you can't compete and therefore you just go quiet.
远为糟糕和痛苦得多的匹配故事。或者他们指出故事中发生好事的那部分，或者指出本来可能发生更糟糕事情的部分，你知道，“哦，我今天上班的通勤太糟糕了。我太沮丧了。我到公司时气得要命。我根本不想待在那儿。”然后他们说：“嗯，从光明面来看，至少，你知道，我今天经历了什么？好吧，至少，你知道，你的车不像我的那样爆炸了，所以你还有值得高兴的事。”这就好比，当这种情况发生时，它会立即切断你表达自己感受的能力，因为要么你需要为这种经历辩护，要么你无法与之竞争，因此你只能选择沉默。
And there is this incredible book about this exact concept called Bright Sided, how the Relentless Promotion of Positive Thinking has undermined America. And it talks about how by stamping out negative thoughts or villainizing negative emotions, we become very two-dimensional. We learn pretty quickly that actually being truthful, looking at, for comfort rather than solutions or optimism is going to be met with toxic positivity. So eventually we just become our happy moments. We just show people the good things.
有一本关于这个精确概念的不可思议的书，名叫《Bright Sided》（盲目乐观：积极思维的无情推广是如何破坏美国的）。书中谈到，通过扑灭消极想法或妖魔化消极情绪，我们变得非常单一。我们很快就会了解到，事实上，表现得真实、寻求安慰而不是解决方案或乐观，将会遭到毒性积极的迎头痛击。所以最终我们变成了我们快乐的时刻。我们只向人们展示美好事物。
And everyone looks at each other thinking, wow, her life is really perfect. Her life is really amazing. Whilst you think the same thing about them. And essentially the author makes this very convincing argument that toxic positivity has made us inauthentic. And I tend to agree. let me play devil's advocate for a second before we fully jump into the consequences of this. You know, we do see toxic positivity everywhere. And you know what? Sometimes it is only natural to
每个人看着对方，心里想：哇，她的生活真的很完美。她的生活真的很棒。而你对他们也有同样的看法。本质上，作者提出了一个非常令人信服的论点，即毒性积极让我们变得不真实。我也倾向于赞同这一点。在我们完全深入探讨这一后果之前，让我先扮演一下魔鬼的代言人一会儿。你知道，我们确实到处都能看到毒性积极。你知道吗？有时，想要
want to see the bright side of what we're going through. It can be useful and it can also be intuitive. As humans, both, you know, evolutionarily but also socially, we naturally prefer positive emotions. They indicate greater happiness, greater satisfaction. They create greater less emotional pain and disharmony, less social friction, we would probably prefer to not get bogged down in hard things. There are also just people who are really optimistic. It's not that they are necessarily toxic in their optimism. It's just how they come. And I think a lot of people would probably look at those explanations that I just gave of people trying their hardest to relate to somebody else through a positive lens and be like, what's the problem? What's the problem here? Of course,
看到我们正在经历事情的光明面，是再自然不过的了。这既有用，也很直观。作为人类，无论是在进化上还是在社会交往中，我们自然更喜欢积极的情绪。它们预示着更大的幸福、更大的满足感。它们创造了更多更少的痛苦和不和谐，更少的社会摩擦，我们可能更倾向于不陷入困难的事情中。也有一些人本身就很乐观。这并不是说他们的乐观本质上是有毒的。这只是他们的天性。我想很多人大概会看着我刚才对那些通过积极视角竭力与他人共情的人的解释，然后会问：“有什么问题吗？这里有什么问题？”当然，
it's better to be happy than sad. You know, of course, this lightens the mood. People want to be around you. People want to be your friend. People want to be happy. And I really do understand that. And I'm not saying that in these instances there isn't room for resilience. There isn't room for gratitude. There isn't room for problem solving. But the thing is, is that those things are healthy coping mechanisms, when we overly rely on them, when our solution to anything bad is just be grateful for what you have, or, okay, just get over it and keep your chin up. That is toxic positivity versus healthy positivity. These happy good vibes become toxic when it involves avoiding and suppressing, minimizing or rejecting negative feelings. And let's be real, that doesn't actually
快乐总比悲伤好。你知道，这当然能活跃气氛。人们希望和你在一起。人们想成为你的朋友。人们想要快乐。我真的理解这一点。我并不是说在这些情况下没有韧性的空间。没有感恩的空间。没有解决问题的空间。但关键在于，当我们将这些东西作为健康的应对机制时，当我们过度依赖它们时，当我们面对任何糟糕事情的解决方案只是“感谢你所拥有的”或者“好吧，振作起来，昂首挺胸”时，这就是毒性积极与健康积极的区别。当这些快乐的好氛围涉及回避、压抑、最小化或拒绝负面感受时，它们就会变成有毒的。说实话，这并不能真正
make them go away, that doesn't allow us to make peace with them, the only thing that is occurring is that in the moment, they become invisible. And that means that eventually, they will most likely return with a vengeance later on. So let's talk about the consequences of toxic positivity. First of all, it stigmatizes these so-called negative emotions. And I know that I've been using that word very, that term very frequently negative emotions. Basically what I mean by that is the emotions that are very much villainized by society, things that we kind of cringe at. We would rather not see anger, jealousy, grief, sadness. Often the reason that these emotions I think are so disturbing to some people is because they are so human. And when we see somebody else,
让它们消失，这无法让我们与它们人和解，唯一发生的事情是，它们在当下变得隐形了。这意味着最终，它们很可能会在后来以更猛烈的方式卷土重来。所以让我们来谈谈毒性积极的后果。首先，它给这些所谓的负面情绪贴上了污名化的标签。我知道我一直在非常频繁地使用“负面情绪”这个词。我基本上是指那些被社会妖魔化、让我们感到尴尬的情绪。我们宁愿看不到愤怒、嫉妒、悲伤。通常，我认为这些情绪之所以如此令人不安，是因为它们是如此人性化。当我们看到别人
experiencing them, we so deeply can see ourselves in that feeling. We know what that feels like and I think that kind of makes us feel embarrassed. Like, oh, don't be loud about what it means to be human. And, you know, sometimes being human does, is just kind of shit. Sometimes it just isn't fun. There is not a single person alive today who would say, you know, my entire life has been golden. Everything is great for me. And yet it feels like that is what is, what is, what is, what is kind of expected. These negative emotions, they are what keep us from being a very palatable person, from being somebody who always leaves others feeling in a good mood. If nothing else, these negative emotions, I actually think are really useful because they make our good moments and our good memories
经历它们时，我们在那种感觉中深深地看到了我们自己。我们知道那是什么感觉，我想这某种程度上让我们感到尴尬。就像，别在大庭广众之下表露什么是人性。而且，你知道，有时身为人类，事情就是有点糟糕。有时就是不好玩。活着的没有一个人会说：“你知道，我的一生都是金色的。一切对我来说都太棒了。”然而感觉这就是被期望的。这些负面情绪，正是它们让我们不至于成为一个极其顺从的人，不至于成为那个总是让别人感觉心情很好的人。抛开别的不谈，这些负面情绪实际上真的很有用，因为它们让我们的美好时刻和美好记忆
even more special. They are also a natural reaction to our experiences and they teach us something they have a purpose. And I think our desire to hide them links very closely to the stigma that is directed towards mental health and mental health conditions and mental health struggles. And I don't think that that is an accident. Society is not that great at wanting people to be open about what they're going through. There is a long history of that. And if we've never been taught to accept that this, that this is a dimension of being human. If we continue to keep up this narrative that intense emotions deserve to be hidden, they deserve to be masked by optimism or masked by positivity,
变得更加特殊。它们也是我们经历的自然反应，它们教给我们一些东西，它们有其目的。我认为我们隐藏它们的欲望与针对心理健康、心理健康状况和心理健康挣扎的污名紧密相连。我不认为这不是巧合。社会并不那么善于让人们对他们正在经历的事情保持开放。这有着悠久的历史。如果我们从未被教导去接受这其实是身为人类的一个维度。如果我们继续维持这样一种叙事，即强烈的情绪应该被隐藏，它们应该被乐观所掩盖，或者被积极性所掩盖，
the next generation is taught the same thing. And that is where prejudice and misunderstanding comes from, a failure to really normalize and accept what is typical for most people, which is that we do feel sad and we do feel angry and we do grieve. and that doesn't always need to be stamped out. It makes us feel like we always have to be okay when no one is. And I saw this quote about this from an author that said, this unrealistic optimism towards life is essentially saying,
下一代就会被教导同样的事情。这就是偏见和误解的来源，未能真正正常化和接受对大多数人来说很典型的事情，即我们确实会感到悲伤，我们确实会感到愤怒，我们确实会悲痛。而这并不总是需要被消灭的。它让我们觉得我们必须时刻表现得一切都好，尽管没有人真正如此。我看到一位作家关于这一点的一句话，他说：
whatever you do, don't tell the truth of what it is like to be alive. Don't be authentic. Don't be honest. Don't be open. It's like having a nice illusion of what everything should look like. It's, I don't know, it's not that there is like this greater power. that it's controlling this and making everyone forcing them to look happy. It is like a long pattern and a long history of this going on.
无论你做什么，都不要说出活着的真实感受是什么样的。不要真实。不要诚实。不要敞开心扉。这就像对一切应该看起来的样子抱有一种美好的幻想。这，我不知道，这并不是有什么更大的力量。它控制着这一切，让每个人都看起来很高兴。这是一个漫长的模式和悠久的历史。
And I think it mainly comes down to the effects of shame and embarrassment. We aren't, you know, necessarily coming out and saying, ew, why are you crying? Don't be upset. That makes me so uncomfortable. You know, we aren't being like, can you please stop that? Can you please stop grieving all over the place or stop being, like, stop being, you know, upset all over the place, like, no, stop. That is not necessarily what it's going on. But when we immediately switch gears when someone brings up the emotions that we don't like, and we cover them
而我认为这主要归咎于羞耻感和尴尬感的影响。我们并不是，你知道，必然会冲出来说：“咦，你为什么在哭？别难过。这让我很不舒服。”你知道，我们不会表现得像：“你能停下来吗？请不要到处表现得悲痛欲穿，或者停止，别再像那样心烦意乱了，不，停下。”这不一定就是正在发生的事情。但是，当我们一听到别人提起我们不喜欢的情绪时就立刻切换挡位，然后用积极性
in positivity and we serve them back to them, you know, that is a meaningful enough cue to influence behavior. It is an implicit message to not do that again. Don't do that. We're not outwardly saying it, but everything about our behavior and everything about our treatment of this emotion is telling you just that. And within that reaction, within that interaction that happens, the thing that we're going to feel is a lot of shame, a lot of guilt, a lot of embarrassment that we, you know, even expressed ourselves in the first place and, of course, the stigma lives on. The second consequence of toxic positivity is that it actually makes us feel worse rather than better. And there are dozens of studies to back this up. The less we feel, the more of a positive spin that we put on things, the
把它们包裹起来再端回给他们时，你知道，这就是一个足够有意义的暗示，足以影响行为。这是一个隐性的信息：不要再这样做了。别那样做。我们可能没有大声说出来，但我们的行为方式和我们对这种情绪的处理方式的一切都在向你传达这一点。而在这种反应中，在随后的这种互动中，我们会感受到的是大量的羞耻感、大量的内疚感、大量的尴尬感——因为我们（甚至在一开始）表达了自己，当然，这种污名化也就延续下去了。毒性积极的第二个后果是，它实际上让我们感觉更糟糕，而不是更好。有几十项研究支持这一点。我们感受得越少，我们在事情上投入的积极滤镜就越多，
less that we learn to cope and the more control that that emotion has. This is the classic cycle of avoidance in psychology. We never actually learn what to do with big emotions because the only thing we can think to do is to suppress them or make them light and fluffy, which actually just gives them more importance. It makes them louder, it makes them darker, the cycle repeats. There is a very well-known study from the 80s, and the title of the study is The Paradoxical effects of thought suppression, just some light reading. And it's pretty groundbreaking. What it basically says is that when you are asked not to think about something, the more you immediately want to think about it. So you may have heard of this if I say to you, okay, please,
我们学会应对的就越少，而这种情绪对我们的控制就越多。这是心理学中经典的回避循环。我们从未真正学会如何处理强烈的情绪，因为我们能想到的唯一方法就是压抑它们或者把它们变得轻松飘忽，这实际上只是赋予了它们更多的重要性。这让它们的声音更大，让它们更黑暗，这个循环不断重复。有一个非常著名的80年代的研究，该研究的标题是《思想压抑的悖论效应》，这只是一些轻松的阅读材料。这是具有开创性的。它的基本意思是，当你被要求不要去想某事时，你反而越会立刻想要去想它。所以你可能听说过这个，如果我对你说：“好的，请无论如何，
whatever you do, don't think about a white elephant. No, don't think about it. Don't think about a white elephant. Of course you're thinking about it. And you'll probably keep thinking about it for the rest of the day. If that's my only instruction, don't think about something. don't think about how hard that was. Don't think about how terrified you were, how unhappy you are, make it positive, make it bubbly, make it glowing. Of course, the thing that I'm telling you not to think about implicitly or explicitly is the thing that's going to become louder.
千万不要去想一头白象。不，不要去想它。不要去想一头白象。”你当然会去想它。而且你可能在接下来的整天里都会一直在想它。如果这是我唯一的指令：不要去想某事。不要去想那有多难。不要去想你有多害怕，你有多不快乐，把它变得积极，把它变得乐观，把它变得闪闪发光。当然，我隐式或显式地告诉不要去想的那件事，恰恰会变成声音最大、最让你挥之不去的事。
And that is exactly what is happening here. Your positive thoughts suppress the initial negative ones, and that suppression actually has the reverse effect of creating a preoccupation with the initial event because you didn't get the chance to work through it. You didn't get the chance to truly process how you reacted, perhaps the trauma that it's left, the consequences, none of that. You've just pushed it into a box. There was another study from the 90s that showed something very similar that suppressing feelings can actually make our psychological stress and our psychological suffering more significant and more intense. And that kind of brings me to my next point. Not only does toxic positivity
这正是这里正在发生的事情。你的积极想法压抑了最初的消极想法，而这种压抑实际上产生了相反的效果，导致你对最初的事件更加执着，因为你没有机会去克服它。你没有机会真正处理你的反应，或许还有它留下的创伤、后果，统统没有。你只是把它塞进了一个盒子。90年代的另一项研究显示了非常相似的结果，即压抑感受实际上会使我们的心理压力和心理痛苦更加严重、更加强烈。这恰好引出了我的下一个观点。毒性积极不仅
actually end up making the feelings worse, so kind of having that like backfire effect. It also prevents growth. Now I spoke briefly about this before, but the next step in the toxic positivity disaster timeline is that A, not only do you feel shame and stigma towards your emotion, which B, means that you actually end up feeling worse, but finally, you never actually grow. Now, I am not saying that bad things happen for a reason and that these negative feelings are a lesson, but if there's, you know, anything, any kind of consolation prize, as terrible as it is, it's that when you let yourself feel the hard times, you grow through the hard times. When you apply unrealistic optimism, you don't even get that.
最终会使感受变得更糟，从而产生那种反噬效应。它还会阻碍成长。现在我之前简单谈到过这一点，但毒性积极灾难时间轴上的下一步是，A，你不仅对你的情绪感到羞耻和污名化，这意味着B，你实际上最终感觉更糟，但最终，你永远不会真正成长。现在，我并不是说坏事发生总有原因，这些负面情绪是一个教训，但如果有什么，任何形式的安慰奖的话，那就是，尽管这很糟糕，但当你让自己去感受艰难时期时，你就在艰难时期中成长了。当你应用不切实际的乐观主义时，你连这都得不到。
So not only did the bad things still happen and you still feel terrible, but you also never learn to evolve as a person, you never learn how to respond. You also never get to appreciate how tremendous you are. Like, you were the one who had the courage and the strength and the patience and the will to get through all of that. When we try and be like, well, everything happens for a reason or you could have it worse or look on the bright side, we need to stop there. You know, you were actually dealt a bad hand and you still pushed through. And that is a testament to how amazing you are. And that is a testament to your strength and your problem solving and your hard work. And when you wrap it all up in a nice pink fuzzy bow, you don't actually get the acknowledgement you deserve around how truly resilient
所以不仅坏事依然发生了，你仍然感觉糟糕透顶，而且你永远不会学会作为一个人去进化，你永远不会学会如何应对。你也永远无法欣赏自己是多么的伟大。比如，你才是那个拥有勇气、力量、耐心和意志力熬过这一切的人。当我们试图说“嗯，发生的一切都有原因，或者你的情况可能会更糟，或者看看光明面”时，我们真的需要停下来。你知道，你其实拿到了一手烂牌，但你还是挺过来了。这是对你有多么了不起的证明。这是对你的力量、你的解决问题能力和你的努力工作的证明。当你把这一切都用一个漂亮的粉红色毛绒蝴蝶结包裹起来时，你其实并没有得到你应得的认可，没有人去承认你是多么的坚韧。
you were. So the final consequence of toxic positivity, and in my mind, one of the most convincing as to why we cannot be positive all the time, is that it just isn't the full picture. Your mindset cannot change everything. It is a very privileged perspective to think that thinking good thoughts can shift a situation. Yes, it can definitely shift the way you think about something. You can change how you feel, but the situation and the event remains the same. And I think the big problem I have is that there are certain things that a positive mindset, you know, will not make better. It will not solve. Obviously, like a really big one is things that are like biological or genetic or medical. You know, I've never seen a single article or academic piece of research that has said,
所以毒性积极的最后一个后果，在我看来，也是最具说服力的、说明我们为什么不能一直保持积极的原因之一，就是它根本不是全貌。你的心态无法改变一切。认为美好的想法可以扭转局势，这是一种非常具特权的视角。是的，它绝对可以改变你对某事的看法。你可以改变你的感觉，但情况和事件本身保持不变。我认为我最大的问题在于，有些事情是积极的心态（你知道的）无法改善的。它无法解决。显然，一个非常大的例子是那些属于生物学、遗传学或医学范畴的事情。你知道，我从来没有见过哪怕一篇学术研究说过，
positive thinking shows signs of like improving cancer survival rates or people who suppress negative emotions are less likely to have diabetes or like woman wins award for I don't know for being happy all the time. Congratulations. Happiest woman alive. I've never seen anything like that. And there is a lot that we need to mention about the fact that some people just have it harder and coming into their circumstances, their story, their life, and applying perhaps your more privileged perspective and one in which you can say, just think positive thoughts about it, is kind of not very fair. It's not very fair and it's just not very nice, to be honest.
积极思考显示出提高癌症生存率的迹象，或者压抑负面情绪的人患糖尿病的可能性更小，或者像“某女子因不知何故一直保持快乐而获奖。恭喜你。活着的、最快乐的女人。我从未见过这样的事。”我们需要指出的是，有些人处境更艰难、有着不同的遭遇、故事和人生，如果你带着比较优越的视角去对他们说“只要往好的方面想就行了”，这其实不太公平。这非常不公平，而且老实说，这真的很不友好。
It's not that you're trying to be mean. It's just not very nice. Because imagine sitting there and being like, yeah, it's very easy for you to say, oh, you know, bad things happen for a reason. but if your mum's just died, or if you're going through a war or whatever it is, like, no, that's not the truth. That's not the full truth. The other thing I think of is like, your environment does play a much bigger role than we think, and it sometimes overwhelms our ability to think positively about something. I saw this video from a creator on YouTube the other day, who she's a dietitian specialist, a doctor, dietitian specialist. And she gave the example of like cortisol levels and how there's been this like whole flood in like pseudoscience or I don't know.
这倒不是说你故意想当坏人，只是这么做实在说不上友好。因为想象一下，如果有人坐在那儿听你这么说，心里肯定会想：“是啊，你当然说得轻巧了，噢，你知道的，发生坏事总有它的原因。”但如果你刚失去母亲，或者正经历战争之类的苦难，那根本不是真相。那并非事情的全部真相。我能想到的另一件事是，环境对我们的影响远比我们想象的要大得多，它有时会彻底压垮我们对事物进行积极思考的能力。前几天我在油管上看到一个创作者的视频，她是一位营养学专家、医生，营养学专家。她举了皮质醇水平的例子，以及围绕“如何将负面情绪转化为正面情绪真的有助于降低皮质醇水平”这一主题，近期出现了铺天盖地的伪科学狂潮，或者我也不清楚……
Let's not be so quickest to call it pseudoscience, but this whole flood in research around how changing negative thoughts into positive ones really helps lower your cortisol levels. But she said in this video she's like, yes, that might be true. But none of that is going to be effective if you don't have shelter or you don't have a sense of internal or external safety if you don't have. if you don't have community. Positive thinking, making things lighter, just actually masks certain things that may actually really need to change, that may actually really demand action and demand some form of justice or demand a personal shift.
我们先别急着把它称作伪科学，但围绕这个课题的研究确实铺天盖地。然而她在视频中说，这或许是真的。但如果你连栖身之所都没有，如果你感受不到内在或外在的安全感，如果你没有……如果你连社群都没有，这一切都不会奏效。盲目乐观、把事情想得太轻巧，实际上只是掩盖了某些真正需要改变、真正需要诉诸行动、需要某种正义或需要个人做出彻底转变的问题。
So we've talked about some of the consequences of toxic positivity. It isn't the full picture. It prevents growth. It actually makes us feel worse and it stigmatizes what a normal emotion. I want to talk about the alternative. If we have to abandon our radical optimism, maybe not radical, unrealistic optimism. Radical optimism is still fine. But if we have to abandon our unrealistic optimism, what do we have left? Well, we're going to talk about all of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down. the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more,
因此，我们已经讨论了毒性积极的一些后果。它无法呈现全貌，它会阻碍成长，甚至让我们感觉更糟糕，并且还将正常的情绪污名化。接下来我想谈谈替代方案。如果我们不得不放弃盲目乐观——也许不能算盲目，是不切实际的乐观。理性乐观其实还是可以的。但如果我们必须抛弃不切实际的乐观，我们还剩下什么呢？好了，在经历这段简短的广告之后，我们将深入探讨所有这些以及更多内容。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客栏目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练以及在我们这个奇特现代社会中构建心理韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究员以及其他健康和健身专家展开对话，不仅如此，
to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships. and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
还将带大家穿透那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经深信种子油生来就会引发炎症。我们其实搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的产物。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你终将涅槃重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。这就是在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方播出的《TWO percent》。
Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here,
你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和金·姬姆有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back At It》播客中找到答案。我是山姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。每一集我们都会锁定这里，
unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day,
剖析究竟发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何挺过那段时光的。其中包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈80年代的可卡因。坦白说，84年对我意义重大，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时准备在节目里聊聊可卡因，
but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
但只是为了让大家知道。我的意思是，此时此刻，这是我们第二集探讨可卡因了。所以我开始看出这里面有一条贯穿始终的主线。我们目前还把艾滋病摆上了台面。谢谢你把话说完。我认为没有哪个年份对黑人而言比这更重要了。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine,
真的吗？是的。对我而言，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。欢迎收听《Look Back At It》，节目可在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或任何您收听播客的地方找到。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、也是你们最喜爱的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己十多年在心理健康领域的经验，以及与众多杰出嘉宾的对话。我要聊的有特里普·方丹、
Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about
瑞安·克拉克。有时当我们执着于追求某样东西时，会过度沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于甚至没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。然而我们还在继续追赶。并且我们根本不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在盯着记分牌。生活变成了一场关于
wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯顿·罗斯，因为你们觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要？你们做一个好人是因为心生恐惧吗？因为这完全是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。而且这是两个不同层面的信任。
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search, learn the hard way and listen now.
我希望你们能真正地做一个好人。加入我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，和凯尔·盖恩斯一起，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和人生目标展开真实走心的对话。打开免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。
In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistency in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.
在2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己陷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她证词中的明显漏洞。这引发了一场历时多年的、旨在证明真相的法庭之战。你曾两次篡改这份特定的检测报告，对吗？我篡改过一次检测报告。这需要一支互联网侦探大军才能破案。
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marincini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样遭遇的男子。格雷格，莱斯利，迈克尔·马林奇尼。我的天呐，我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这里是《爱之陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的推进，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I have a little grace for those of us who do genuinely try and see the good. And I will say that I am someone who does try and do that. There is a lot of beauty in finding the joy, despite things being pretty terrible. There is a lot of beauty in seeing the good side of things and trying to find the silver lining. Again, we want the people we love most to be happy. We want to guide them back to a place of feeling good and positive about their circumstances.
女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被正式以欺诈罪起诉。在亚利桑那州实现正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或任何您获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。对于那些真心努力去发现美好事物的人，我总是抱持着几分宽容。而且我也得承认，我本人就是这样一个一直在尝试这么做的人。尽管现实可能相当糟糕，但在其中寻找快乐依然有着极大的美感。看到事物光明的一面并努力寻找一线希望，这其中蕴含着许多美好。同样的，我们希望我们最爱的人能够快乐。我们希望引导他们重新回到那种对自身处境感到美好和积极的状态。
So I totally get the inclination. We want to feel good. It's okay to want to feel good. This, you know, episode isn't about being like, if you want to feel good about yourself, you have toxic positivity. No, I think it's more about whether your version of being positive involves not making space for negative emotions or bad emotions. Complex emotions, we'll call them that. I think complex emotions also sometimes make us uncomfortable because we've never been taught how to process them within ourselves or with others. We have no education or emotional management courses. Like, that's not something that we are taught on or informed on as children, even as adults. So suppression and making everything seem quite positive and lovely
所以我完全理解这种倾向。我们都想感觉良好。想要感觉良好是没有错的。所以，你知道的，这一集并不是要对你们说：“如果你想让自己感觉良好，你就是有毒的积极性。”不，我觉得它更多的是在探讨：你的积极版本是否包含了不给负面情绪或糟糕情绪留出空间？复杂的感情，我们姑且这么称呼它们。我认为复杂的感情有时也会让我们感到不适，因为我们从来没有被教导过如何在自己身上或与他人相处时去消化它们。我们没有任何教育或情绪管理课程。这并不是我们作为儿童甚至成年人时会接受培训或被告知的内容。因此，压抑情绪、让一切看起来都相当积极和美好
is the status quo. But let's talk about some alternatives for actually looking at those complex emotions and, you know, making peace with them. becoming friends with them, becoming friends with your friends, negative emotions, and not bright-siding and not trying to fix everything. So firstly, when you find the desire to suppress a negative or complex emotion is coming up, be honest with the fact that a situation is difficult and break away from the urge to say, it's fine immediately. you're allowed to feel your painful emotions without them becoming you.
就成了现状。但我们来谈谈一些替代方案，如何真正正视这些复杂的感情，你知道的，与它们人和解，与它们做朋友，与你朋友们的负面情绪做朋友，而不是盲目乐观，也不是试图解决一切。所以首先，当你发现自己内心涌起压抑负面或复杂情绪的渴望时，要诚实地承认当前的情况确实很困难，并打破那种立刻说“我很好”的冲动。你完全有权感受痛苦的情绪，同时又不会被这些情绪所吞噬、成为情绪本身。
There was an article from Scientific America that I read in preparation for this episode and it's about 10 years old and it suggests that across multiple studies, multiple case studies, multiple research projects on happiness, it is actually the people who are in touch with their negative emotions who overall experience the greatest levels of well-being and true mastery over their lives. So honestly, you are better off just admitting that something sucks. Just admitting that something is awful. That is okay.
在准备这一期节目时，我读过《科学美国人》上的一篇文章，大约有10年历史了。它表明，通过多项研究、多个案例研究、多个关于幸福的研究项目，那些真正与自己的负面情绪保持联系的人，总体上才体验到了最高水平的幸福感，并对自己的生活拥有了真正的掌控力。所以老实说，你最好还是直接承认有些事情真的很烂。直接承认有些事情糟糕透顶。这完全没问题。
You're going to push on anyways. You are not going to become those feelings. Those feelings are just part of your human experience. I think it's honesty without the extreme pessimism. And I get that that is a fine line to walk. But you are allowed to feel, despair, feel grief, feel whatever it is. is and that doesn't need to be everything. That doesn't need to become you. You know, you don't have to get wrapped up in ruminating and letting it interrupt your life. If you make space and time for your
无论如何，你还是要继续前行。你不会变成那些情绪。这些情绪只是你人生体验的一部分。我认为这是一种去除了极端悲观主义的诚实。我明白这是一条很难把握的界限。但你完全有权去感受、去绝望、去悲伤、去感受任何情绪，而且这不需要占据你的全部。这不需要变成你的全部。你知道的，你不需要深陷于反刍思考之中，让它打乱你的生活。如果你腾出空间和时间来容纳你的
negative emotions and then I'm like, okay, I acknowledge that this exists. I acknowledge that I feel this way and I've given myself time to feel that and now I'm going to move on. And if this emotion bubbles up again, I will look at it. I will hold it. I will hold it. I will sit with it, and when we're going to try again. We're going to move through the same process every single time. So when the urge to run and kind of cover up occurs, stay put, fight the instinct. There is this scene in Harry Potter. I think it's like the first one.
负面情绪，然后我会想：“好吧，我承认这个情况的存在。我承认我有这种感受，我已经给自己时间去感受它了，现在我要继续前行了。”如果这种情绪再次涌现，我会去正视它。我会拥抱它。我会接纳它。我会带着它静静相处，然后我们再试一次。每一次我们都要经历这个相同的过程。所以，当逃避和掩饰的冲动出现时，留在原地，抗拒这种本能。哈利·波特里有这样一幕。我想应该是第一部吧。
Yeah, the first Harry Potter, Sorcerer's Stone, Philosopher's Stone, where they're getting, Harry or Ron, and one of them is like getting, like, suffocated by those, by the vines. And Hermione goes, just relax. just relax. I think when we try and make everything positive all the time, that is the vines tightening around us. We're fighting back again what is a very natural instinct to feel. And it actually ends up suffocating us. It feels counterintuitive, but acceptance is where we find a lot of freedom. One way that I like to think about it is that sadness, anger, grief, jealousy, pessimism,
是的，第一部《哈利·波特：魔法石》里，他们去拿……哈利还是罗恩，其中一个人被那些藤蔓缠得快窒息了。然后赫敏说，放松点，放松点。我觉得，当我们试图无时无刻把一切都变得积极时，那就像是藤蔓在周围越勒越紧。我们在反抗一种非常本能的感受。而这最终会让我们窒息。这听觉上似乎有点反直觉，但接纳恰恰是我们获得许多自由的地方。我喜欢的一种思考方式是，悲伤、愤怒、悲痛、嫉妒、悲观，
they're like little creatures in my house. They're like little dust mites or little kittens. You know, my house is my brain, and in it there are all these things kind of wandering around. And sometimes it might jump out and scare me. You know, I'll be pottering around, and this little dust might be in my way. My grief might be in my way. My pessimism might be in my way. But it's just a house guest. I don't need to lock them in a room because that way they're going to become a lot louder.
它们就像我房子里的小生物。它们就像小尘螨或小猫咪。你知道，我的房子就是我的大脑，里面所有这些东西都在四处游荡。有时它可能会跳出来吓我一跳。你知道的，当我四处溜达时，这个小尘螨可能会挡我的路。我的悲伤可能会挡我的路。我的悲观可能会挡我的路。但它只是一个做客的客人。我不需要把它们锁在一个房间里，因为那样的话，它们的动静会变得更大。
They're going to screech and wail. They're less disruptive when I let them roam about. when I know that these complex emotions are in the house, but they're not scary to me. They're not something that I need to run from or lock away. When those negative emotions come up, hold them, hug them, let them pass through. Don't feel the need to immediately get rid of them, but find a way to integrate them through things that are healthy coping mechanisms like talk therapy, like journaling, and like some catharsis or physical expression.
它们会尖叫和哭喊。当我让它们四处走动时，它们的破坏性就会小一些。当我意识到这些复杂的负面情绪就在屋里，但它们对我来说并不可怕。它们不是我需要逃避或锁起来的东西。当那些负面情绪出现时，接纳它们，拥抱它们，让它们过去。不要觉得需要立刻摆脱它们，而是要通过健康的应对机制将它们整合起来，比如谈话疗法、写日记，以及一些宣泄或身体表达。
This is another big piece of advice that I have. make hard emotions tangible. Things like art therapy, that is a huge component of art therapy, is taking things that we would otherwise push aside and actually making them tangible, making them physical, giving them a home and giving them, you know, a place to be free and a place to come out. Same thing with a lot of physical therapies and not physical therapies in terms of the I broke a bone sense,
这是我给出的另一个重要建议：让沉重的情绪变得有形。诸如艺术疗法之类的东西，这是艺术疗法的一个重要组成部分，就是把我们原本会推开的东西变得切实可行，让它们具体化，给它们一个家，给它们一个自由释放和宣泄的地方。许多身体疗法也是如此，这里指的不是那种我骨折了意义上的疗法，
but in terms of like expressing negative, emotions through your body, getting involved in a boxing class and a running class and a hit workout, something that provides your body with a release. We know that we feel a lot of emotions in our body. How can we expend that energy and give it a place to go? I think when it comes to navigating the urge to go positive when a friend is sharing or when you're giving advice and you're noticing that, okay, wait, I keep steering into the positive lane here. How do I bring this back so that my friend feels acknowledged? That's a whole other thing.
而是指通过你的身体表达负面情绪，参与拳击课、跑步课和HIIT高强度训练，做一些能让你的身体得到释放的事情。我们知道我们在身体中感受到了很多情绪。我们如何消耗这些能量并给它一个去处？我认为，当需要应对去保持积极的冲动时，比如当朋友在分享，或者当你在给别人建议，而你注意到，等一下，我一直在往积极的轨道上靠。我该如何把话题拉回来，让朋友觉得被认可？那是完全另一回事。
But I think replace your unrealistically optimistic statements with realistic ones. And with ones that at their center, at their core, are statements of acceptance, a statements of approval for these emotions. For example, if someone is like, oh my God, I know it's been four months, I know it's been a year, but I just am still hung up on my ex. I'm still miserable. Instead of being like, okay, but I feel like it's time to like get over it.
但我认为，可以用现实的陈述来代替你那些不切实际的乐观言论。并且要用那些以接纳为核心、以对这些情绪的认可为核心的言论。比如，如果有人说，哦天哪，我知道已经过去四个月了，我知道已经过去一年了，但我还是对前任念念不忘。我还是觉得很痛苦。与其说，好吧，我觉得是时候走出来了。
Like maybe you should go and find somebody better because like there's definitely somebody better out there for you. Be like, I'm listening. I can totally see why that would be really, really hard. If somebody, you know, your friend, I've had a lot of friends recently get laid off from their tech jobs. There's huge like redundancies in that area. If your friend is like, oh, I got laid off. This is just like the most terrible thing. Instead of being like, well, in the bright side, at least like, you know, you have savings.
就像也许你应该去找个更好的人，因为外面肯定有更好的人适合你。不如说，我在听。我完全理解为什么这会非常非常难。如果有人，比如你的朋友，我最近有很多朋友的技术工作被裁了。那个领域有大规模的裁员。如果你的朋友说，哦，我被裁了。这简直是最糟糕的事情。与其说，嗯，从光明的一面来看，至少，你知道，你还有积蓄。
At least, you know, maybe your parents could help with your rent. At least like you'll find a new job pretty soon. At least, you know, you always said that you hated that job. Maybe that's a good thing. Sometimes you just got to say, you know, failure is sometimes a part of life and your feelings around that are super valid. How can I help? Sometimes bad things just happen. I'm really sorry.
至少，你知道，也许你父母可以帮你付房租。至少，你知道，你很快就会找到新工作。至少，你知道，你总是说你讨厌那份工作。也许这是一件好事。有时候你不得不说，你知道的，失败有时是生活的一部分，你对这件事的感受是完全合理的。我能帮上什么忙吗？有时候坏事就是会发生。我真的很抱歉。
There's no reason. What do you want me to do? not like what do you want me to do but like what would you like me to do how can i help you hear what's what are you thinking just explain how you're thinking just explain how you're feeling to me and i will sit and i will absorb all of that complexity all of that outrage all of that negativity i'll just absorb it for you and i'm not going to sit there and be like yeah this happened for a reason because i can acknowledge that maybe you don't want to hear that right now there is a time and a place for being positive.
没有原因。你想让我做什么？不是像“你想让我做什么”那种语气，而是像“你希望我怎么做，我该怎么帮你好呢，你听到了吗，你在想什么，只要向我解释你的想法，向我解释你的感受，我会坐在这里，吸收所有的复杂情绪，所有的愤怒，所有的负面情绪，我会为你吸收这些，我不会坐在那里说，是的，这件事发生是有原因的，因为我可以承认，也许你现在不想听到这个。凡事都有时间和地点去保持积极。
There is a time and a place. And I totally respect the need to want to make somebody feel better. But sometimes you've got to look for the signs that that's what they want as well. And you know what the easiest sign is is when they say, can you just make me feel better about this? And then you can make them feel, and then you can be a little bit more positive about things. Or when you can see that they're moving from wanting to vent to wanting advice,
凡事都有时间和地点。我完全尊重想要让别人感觉好一点的需求。但有时你必须寻找迹象，看这也是他们所想要的。你知道最简单的迹象是什么吗？就是当他们说：你能让我对此感觉好点吗？然后你就可以让他们感觉好点，然后你就可以对事情采取更积极的态度。或者当你看到他们从想要宣泄转变为想要寻求建议，
or if they are someone who does actually respond pretty well to that, they're like a good friend or a partner like you probably know when they're ready to hear those positive statements. Until then, just be really genuine and authentic in your interactions with them. Kind of avoid using those cliches or those platitudes that may not be relevant or helpful. I just want to finish up by saying, one more time, you don't have to feel good about your life,
或者如果他们确实是那种对这种建议反应相当好的人，比如一个好朋友或伴侣，你可能知道他们什么时候准备好听到这些积极的陈述。在此之前，在与他们的互动中保持真诚和真实。尽量避免使用那些可能不相关或无益的陈词滥调或老生常谈。最后我想说的是，再强调一次，你不需要对你的生活感觉良好，
about yourself, about the world all the time. In fact, as those studies were telling us, sometimes it's actually helpful to feel deep, vulnerable, complex feelings about a situation about your life. Those feelings not only remind you that you're a human and that you can feel a full rainbow spectrum of emotions, they also do help you grow, they do help you problem solve, they do help you be empathetic, they help you connect with other people. and they stop us from being one-dimensional people. Like that book was saying that author was saying, when the focus is always on happy experiences, happy emotions,
对你自己，对世界一直感觉良好。事实上，正如那些研究所告诉我们的那样，有时对某种情况、对你的生活产生深刻、脆弱、复杂的情感实际上是有帮助的。这些感觉不仅提醒你是一个人类，你能够感受到丰富多彩的彩虹般的情绪，它们还能真正帮助你成长，帮助你解决问题，帮助你富有同理心，帮助你与他人建立联系。并且它们能阻止我们成为单维度的人。就像那本书里说的，那位作者说的，当焦点总是放在快乐的体验、快乐的情绪上，
getting back to joy, getting back to what feels good, making just like when the only ambition is to have as many happy moments as possible, and that is like it's a very concrete task. I think sometimes we really forget how special it is when times are good. And we also sometimes forget what it means to be truly feeling.
回到快乐中，回到感觉良好的事物中，把目标仅仅设定为拥有尽可能多的快乐时刻，这就像是一个非常具体的任务。我想有时我们真的忘记了当好时光来临时的那种特别。我们也常常忘记真正去感受意味着什么。
And that sometimes like those emotions really remind us of what matters and what we care about. And as much as like obviously we love sharing happy, fun memories with our friends, I think true bonding and true connection sometimes actually does come from those dark and hard and sometimes painful moments where you're honest and you're feeling and you're authentic. So I really hope that you enjoyed this episode. It's a bit more rambly than I normally do, but this is just a topic that I'm really passionate about and didn't want to script it as much. I just kind of wanted to talk about it.
有时候那些情绪确实提醒了我们什么才是最重要的，什么是我们在乎的。尽管我们显然很喜欢和朋友分享快乐、有趣的记忆，但我认为真正的凝聚力和真正的连接有时确实来自于那些黑暗、艰难甚至痛苦的时刻，在那些时刻里你是诚实的、在感受的并且是真实的。所以我真的希望你喜欢这一集。它比我平时做的节目要更随性一些，但这只是一个我真正热衷的话题，所以我不想把它写得那么照本宣科。我只是想谈论它。
Have a bit of a discussion. See if you guys related, if this is something that you've experienced. If you also think that there is perhaps a problem with being too positive all the time. So thank you so much for listening. I hope that you've made it this far. If so, make sure that you are following me on Instagram or following me here on Spotify, Apple Podcasts. Wherever you are listening right now
聊一聊。看看你们是否感同身受，这是否是你们经历过的事情。如果你也认为对凡事都过于积极可能存在问题。非常感谢你们的收听。希望你们能听到这里。如果是的话，请确保在Instagram上关注我，或者在这里的Spotify、Apple Podcasts上关注我。无论你现在在哪里收听
and if you can leave a five-star review, that is incredibly helpful, and it of course helps the show to grow. Until next time, stay safe, be kind to yourself, be gentle to yourself, and we will talk soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs
如果你能留下一个五星好评，那将非常有帮助，这当然也有助于节目的成长。我们下次再见，注意安全，对自我好一点，对自己温柔一点，我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是走楼梯的人的比例，
when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist,
在也有自动扶梯可选的情况下。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的完整人。收听《2%》。即数字TWO，在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过，
They take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
她们开始自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。在Iheart radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。
On the Look Back at a podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
在《回顾过去》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我是个很大的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
比如马马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《艰难中学习》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·加姆斯。这个空间关乎黑人群体的男性经历，进行在任何地方都不安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行这些对话。
How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
有多少男人穿着铠甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在IHard radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或任何你获取播客的地方收听《艰难中学习》。这是一个IHart播客。真人保证。谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。